sure maybe in the Ninja world those who
break the rules are scum but you know
what someone who doesn't care about
their friends is even worse
I'm gonna get stronger than Kakashi and
sensei's cleaner than anyone I'll
protect the entire village and reap
tobiko
my Sharingan but I'll become one of your
eyes I don't see what the future holds
up today you are our Savior you are my
dad
you're Obito so I'm going to rebuild it
time ii sage of the six paths i am the
one who is chosen to create a world of
dreams and lead everyone to peace
there's no reason to force yourself to
walk down a dangerous path that doesn't
even have an end in sight I don't want
to know how to walk down some easy path
I want to know how to walk down the
dangerous one
Hokage is the person who walks in front
of everyone and bears all the pain
you'll never have to walk over the
corpses of the Cylons you're really just
a hidden leaf ninja who dreams of
becoming Hokage your obito uchiha I'll
be the leader this time you're my backup
Kakashi it'll be our first time teaming
up in a while don't screw this up Obito
let's go yeah you failed to accomplish
anything you are just a powerless
shinobi
right
the one who wanted to be Hokage obito
uchiha I could never walk in a straight
line but now I finally reached my goal
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
you
you